I wanted to have a fum over last night
and so our question of the day is every
time
goodmorning believe nation today's
message is help others over to you Dalai
Lama is the ultimate source of
satisfaction within ourself if you do
wrong things mainly harming other you
get negative consequences if you do
helping other bring more happiness to
other you get benefit more inner
strength there and more sort of
confidence of purpose of life and
fulfillment about that purpose then you
always feel happy so I invited Alex from
Toronto that sauce with me here to be a
part of this episode because he shared a
really inspiring story his one word is
belonging and he had a great story of
what happened him today that involved
helping others and so I said Alex here
on the show and tell the story part of
my credo for the word belong is to
validate others through honest
appreciation and I've been working super
hard to do it on every conversation it
makes a huge impact I believe on people
when people are seen and when you
recognize them for their personal
successes or their struggles and like
the courage that it takes to go through
them so what happened was I was
downstairs I was making some copies with
a woman who's a single mother her son is
in Australia he's 19 years old she's
supporting him she's new to the country
she's a accounting assistant and her
English is not that great but it's quite
good actually anyway so we're talking
and she's kind of lonely she misses her
son and all these things are happening
I'm listening
while she's photocopying and printing
things for me and she tells me that
she's going to Grade 12 to do night
school to work on her English and I'm
hopefully next year to do college and so
I listened to this and I absorbed it
right like that's part of what I do I
love to
to people and I took the copies and I
left and I was I was walking out I felt
this like a huge dread over me that I
didn't really do a good job with her I
didn't make her feel special I didn't
make her feel that she belongs and I
didn't validate her and so at first my
instinct was you know what next time I
go I'll see her I'll talk to her
but that kind of you know cop out and
that kind of uncomfortable situation of
me walking back I'm like you know what
I'm gonna fight through it so I
literally after walking out of the store
I walked back in scared and nervous I
don't know why I was scared but it's
just awkward you know when you say
goodbye to someone you commit to it
you're like I'll see you later
and then you run into them again they're
like oh hi we just said goodbye haha so
I hate awkwardness but I went back in
and I told her and I said you know what
it takes a lot of courage it's not easy
to go back to school to do night school
to go into college and you find
something new for yourself you want to
find out new career paths and I just
want to just recognize you first I shook
her head she lit up she smiled she
laughed a little bit it was just a great
experience and I think the huge lesson
for me and and for anyone who's watching
this is that it's never too late to
first of all do the right thing and to
make a difference in other people's
lives and to help others it made me feel
more fulfilled it made her more happy
about her life and her situation and
that she's not alone in this right even
if her you know maybe other people are
not recognizing her so it's never too
late help others even if you walk away
from the situation what's your family
your friends totals changes it's never
too late to do the right thing and make
a difference I love it it's a good story
right it's a good story
right guys I was all set to record this
video and helping others and I was
leaving to go work at the coffee shop
it's Alex come on you got to share that
story with us and say I'm in let's do it
so give Alex some love in the comments
for being brave and coming on with us
spontaneously and also doing a great
thing to help others so the question
today today is what was a proud moment
in your life recently where you did the
uncomfortable thing but the right thing
leaving the comments below we're gonna
join in the discussion finally want to
give a quick shout out to Leo from ask
Leo calm Leo thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book really means
a lot cause you watching you want a
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to grab a copy of the
book and email in your seats
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is I
will see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso I hate this is
the worst part like I asked so many
questions in my life it's just how I am
and I can't think of a question right
now that's weird
so the question they today is